some say Paris is the city of love it's
certainly a place where love is big
business
Shauna worked for eight years as a call
girl she's a former sales woman and she
discovered the profession by chance I
was working in a boutique one day a man
came in he became my lover because I
speak several languages he paid for me
to take expensive trips to London and
Geneva and an event one evening I met
other girls working as escorts they told
me how to find more clients so I gave up
my day job
Shauna spent lots of time in luxury
hotels her clients included businessmen
lawyers and prominent public figures she
won't say more men frequently booked
prostitutes like her but with the utmost
discretion I had to know what was on at
the theatres and be able to talk about
politics you need good general knowledge
I want to George in the head as he said
first you go out to eat and then comes
this magic moment and things go further
back then I really enjoyed these
encounters Shauna says the fun stopped
when the Sarkozy government prohibited
all types of advertising for
prostitution business moved to the
Internet where prostitution rings
operate illegally that meant that Shauna
had to find a pimp from then on she was
forced to accept a client's that he
chose she could no longer set limits dr.
Monica under customer behavior changed
completely they became very rough and
wanted to get down to business right
away
they have no respect for us anymore
I'm Priscilla it is picture the violence
of the French sex trade was made public
by the scandal surrounding the former
head of the International Monetary Fund
Dominique strauss-kahn after facing
charges in court for sexually assaulting
a hotel maid in New York there were
accusations of his involvement in a
prostitution ring in the French town of
Lille prosecutors are investigating
strauss-kahn is refusing to comment on
the allegations he says he didn't know
the women were prostitutes the French
public though finds that hard to believe
a kiss-and-tell novel written by a
former lover is a best-seller a highly
placed source in Paris says the sexual
escapades of French politicians are
tolerated but only to a certain point
yes you could even say what shocked the
French is that dominique strauss-kahn
apparently forced women to do things
that they didn't want to do whether it
was an affair in New York or in the
Carlton in Lille sex workers say making
the business illegal has led to an
increase in brutality bordellos are
prohibited and selling sex on the street
is frowned upon
they say that keeps the violence
undercover
Seana sought help only after her pimp
beat her so badly that she had to be
hospitalized she went to this group in
Paris her pimp ended up in court does it
work when it sells this helps the women
to recover it's important that they're
recognized as victims of a crime
frequently they've been so humiliated
that they've lost all self esteem and
believes they have no rights at all they
should get all the water in the case of
Dominique strauss-kahn the advocacy
group is a co plaintiff this really has
us in the spotlight but there are
witnesses and there's evidence it's up
to the judges now I'm not worried if
strauss-kahn did something wrong then
he's got to pay the price public
prosecutors in Paris often demand jail
terms of several years in these kinds of
cases but the judges mostly issue
suspended sentences unless the French
government puts a stop to illegal
prostitution rings prostitutes will need
better protection until now women like
Shauna have worked illegally making them
ineligible for welfare benefits France
we simply pretend prostitution doesn't
exist but we haven't really banned it
because we know that there are
prostitutes in every society unlike
Germany the Netherlands or Spain we
haven't set up a legal framework to
protect sex workers Julian okay de la
cosa to show you a video maximum leader
a river Shauna has given evidence in
court about her clients but she's afraid
to tell all due to fear of reprisals she
says she wants to get out of the sex
trade and she's looking for another job
far from the glitz and glamour of luxury
hotels